au jeu des européens c'est horrible
est-ce que non seulement il a fait que
des choses horribles il a dit des choses
horribles et on est dans une époque qui
quand même totalement crispé sur les
mots le politiquement correct il n'est
pas que mccarthy sectorielle à l'envers
il est bon mais si vous interrogez il ya
netanyahu
il pense que c'est le meilleur président
qu'on ait jamais vu les saoudiens aussi
les émirats tient aussi contre l'iran
bon si vous interrogez les polonais ils
adorent trump voiliers et les les
américains qui essaie un coup de
sanctions de torpiller le gazoduc entre
la russie et l'allemagne
je vous prétexte de d'empêcher une
dépendance extrême de l'allemagne est en
réalité pour écouler le le gaz de
schiste en europe via la pologne bon
hein et polarise la dent trump donc
aider il ya un sou de gens dans le faut
pas penser uniquement comme des
européens de l'ouest bien pensants
desbriel électorat de trump et qui est
quand même un bloc notamment les
évangélistes ils sont déchaînés et il
adore trump en fait mais quand même au
jour d'aujourd'hui je pastis passera pas
ce que beaucoup savaient dans les
élections moderne plongeon se
déterminent au dernier moment
il ya même un pro chantage qui n'est pas
nul les gens qui décident en allant vers
bureaux de vote n'ont en tout cas on va
dire aux états unis que ça va être
l'état de l'économie en octobre et
l'idée que les gens se font de leur
situation par rapport à l'économie
mais quand même aujourd'hui on est début
septembre
depuis quelques mois il a en moyenne dix
points de retard sur bayonne
et comme les démocrates ont choisi un
centriste quelqu'un modérée de centre
gauche associé à obama ils ont pas pris
un des gauchistes du parti démocrate
neela ghoshal anciennes comme dame et
warren qui vient programme est
d'ailleurs très très très sérieux très
sérieux même pas fiscalement c'était un
plus lourd pour les américains ils ont
plus de chances de gagner avec biden et
le fait qu'il soit un peu de terre non
on n'a rien retenu de lui mon peut rien
lui reprocher non plus voyez donc un peu
on peut projeter sur bail donne l'idée
qu'on veut plus de 3 me
[Musique]